good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and
happy
friday friday you gotta get down on
friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend party
you're oh i'm going for like the high
went straight for the bridge yeah i'm
going for the high energy moment this is
a high energy podcast and we are five
days in a row killing it you went
straight for the bridge i just need to
get a bunch of things off my chest
really quickly oh jesus christ okay
first of all this episode's dedicated to
brew because he was sick all morning and
i'm just thinking of brew right now
our brew stands out there and any other
puppy who might have had diarrhea this
morning
okay all of them said this episode's
dedicated to them and to the parents who
picked up after them
i stand with the parents you can't say
that was me no of course not
second thing we need to talk about your
foch
you guys claudia has had a thotch
renaissance okay so let's just start at
the beginning honestly about my face
because yesterday jackie and i you know
sometimes it's hard to be so creative
and funny all the time and some days you
know some months we struggle to come up
with content for the patreon because
like we've literally spoken and vlogged
everything but we refuse to do anything
that's not premium or we never give it
less than 100 percent we've never
actually done some vlogs that we have
not posted because they were not premium
i remember shopping for bridesmaids
dresses actually i think we posted it
but it wasn't an episode we were like
this is really bad yeah oh also when we
were um upstate during the pandemic
we did like the most stupid ass vlog
like
i was like gonna dye my hair and then i
realized i had to bleach my hair so i
was like not gonna do it and then we did
like a we went to like the pharmacy
because there was nothing to do up there
and then we did like a haul from the
pharmacy and we literally were like
we're scrapping this it's a piece of
[ __ ] but you know what now i feel like
if we watch it was probably amazing it
probably had its moments but so
yesterday we had the idea we've actually
been thinking about this idea for a
while that i was going to do claudia's
makeup well the idea is that we'll do
both of like we'll do yeah
eventually you'll do mine we'll see
about that we're doing it but yesterday
i went over to claudia's i did her
makeup from scratch the vlog is on our
patreon patreon.com morning toast the
vlog is so incredible it's
honestly i watched it three times and
made ben watch it i was like so proud of
it it was so funny so the vlog is so
enjoyable but also like what we were
being hysterical what came out of it
which was this new look for you so when
i think of videos like that i just
assumed i was going to be leaving my
house like looking like a clown like it
was like a funny thing we did haha we're
so crazy i was not expecting to look
like a bride on her wedding day like not
at all
she looked so stunning and of course you
know your face is your face how
different can you really look and also
i'm not you know a professional makeup
artist like doing crazy looks but just
like the way that i go about the
thoughts clearly is so different from
you and we both thought you looked
amazing at the end you guys are gonna
die from the results like and so i went
out to dinner last night and i did my
makeup again this morning and both times
i've tried to like i took a lot a lot of
technique away from our time together
and i tried to apply those techniques to
my routine and i've changed things up
like i'm wearing brown eyeshadow i don't
know if you noticed
and it's just not the same no it's not
the same what am i looking like today
it ain't right
it ain't right first of all about the
brown eyeshadow like do you stick to
just half the lid
it looks like you went up here a little
bit okay i have like a [ __ ] up spray
tan right now no no no it's not the
spray tan
it's just it looks like you went all
over the lid but not just 50 and down
the halfway line okay look that's not
really where i'm i'm feeling concerned
about the luke it's my skin
do you do the concealer i did the
concealer i did the contour i baked like
i did everything you did even though i
never do that stuff and you know what's
so funny is like now that i think about
it i actually think the way you do your
face is like perfect for someone like me
and the way that i do my face normally
actually i think is perfect for you too
why because you just have like this like
perfect little face like it doesn't need
like shaping you know
like sculpting yeah
interesting okay that's an interesting
point that does make me curious to see
you do my makeup so it was such a good
vlog check it out and then just let us
know if you want me to do jackie's
makeup because it has to happen and it's
only right that's what everyone said i'm
gonna allow it because you know i let my
guard down for the patreon but the idea
of you coming at my face with your hands
and just wear gloves
no i just don't like my it's not about
your hands like i don't like my face
being touched even if it's touched with
a glove nobody likes their face being
touched but you know what we get over it
for the patreon well for the patreon but
i dislike it more than most people is
that the you said you had a few things
to say right from the get-go was that it
was just dedicated to brew and your
newfound foch thank you for
acknowledging the fotch in the room
and our hearts are with bruno truly and
honestly thank you so much that really
means a lot he's on my mind today while
bruno is having such a hard day theo's
having the best day of his life because
due to his parents miscommunication he
had two breakfast this morning and hence
being two breakfast ticks tbt two
breakfast ticks and two breakfast takes
i think he comes around
twice a year i think it happens way more
really yeah like once every couple
months and so he must think it's his
birthday once every couple months like
this is gonna be the best day ever plus
he has spa services today he went for a
walk like it's a beautiful weather day
it's a great day to be theo i think theo
thinks it's his birthday today not to
rub in you know
obviously what
bruno is going through but theo is
having an amazing day well you know what
that actually that makes me feel good
because at least one of my boys
is is on a good page today so dear evan
hansen came out last night i think i'm
going to see it tonight how fun for you
do you want to come
no i know well so not unless it's on
streamers the reviews are so atrocious
like people are saying it's the worst
movie they've ever seen yeah but i don't
know i'm going into it with an open mind
i love the movie i love the show and i
love ben platt so i think how bad could
it be i know the music is so good like
really how bad could it be i don't know
things are really bad these days and
it's the duo who created greatest
showman what are their names pasek and
paul that's what i'm saying
nobody's complaining about the music
though like if if the movie is [ __ ] like
don't break take it out on pastor don't
bring pasic in politics no passage and
paul did their job the soundtrack is
flames and they've got such good collabs
to like cover some of the songs for the
soundtrack like pasek and paul
understood the assignment don't come for
them don't look for them leave passing
and paul's name ouchman i think if the
movie is bad it's only up to one man
because he's the star he's the writer
he's the producer he's been playing he's
not the writer
didn't he like create the show he worked
with like the people who wrote it like
it was built around him okay he didn't
like write it in his bedroom and bring
it downstairs to his dad who was a
producer and said like make this for me
no so he worked with
producers like they built the character
around him he was very involved from the
get-go but he didn't write the show but
then with the movie um i do believe he
was you know hella involved because his
dad is a producer and that's why people
are just like not into this film because
ben platt is like a 30 year old playing
a 16 year old and i don't know when we
started caring about things like that
because it's been going on for centuries
um but the nepotism of it all but like
i don't know i i'm very selective with
my nepotism like certain epotistic
virtues seem to bother me and others
don't and i'm just biased nepotistic
virtues really do bother me but when
someone has talent like ben
i just forgot to say it
doesn't say ben paul yeah sure ben platt
is
an extreme rare talent his singing his
even contributions to the show just
everything he touches he's a talent
whether or not his parents are famous
like he deserves the success that he's
having that doesn't bother me no there's
like one instance of nepotism i feel
like you know what it is that grinds my
gears and i would never say it but like
i really really cause like talk about
having no talent but i'm not going to
say who it is i actually don't know what
you're talking about yeah catch me up
later you know if you really thought
long and hard you would know okay well
i'm not going to sit here and think but
of course we can talk about it later um
so yeah that's what's going on i went to
karaoke last night and i kind of you
know took your words from yesterday's
show i was talking about it all night
like jackie said i can't sing she used
to be mine like i was telling everyone
and you know what
you had a point it wasn't great it
wasn't great and i thought it was and i
think maybe every time i've sang it
before i was like really drunk and you
know i think i'm like amazing that
you're doing something but i was looking
through it with critical lenses last
night and i did not do anything actually
i did nothing of the sword
well at least you can be honest with
yourself no and i was like john film
this i'm gonna show jackie and like i
literally deleted the video it was an
atrocity and at least you can now see
that i'm only ever looking out for you
and that i'm never just like saying
stuff to hurt your feelings no i know
but like
just because you're not saying it to
hurt my feelings doesn't mean that it
doesn't no but that was like when you
call me chessy
yeah but you know the truth words
and so it did and so it did for you
i [ __ ] like right now could really go
for some of chessy's chili
yeah or her pancakes or her grilled
cheese remember she made that whole face
for hallie when she got home and halle
ate not one bite of it except the corner
of the grilled cheese i can't relate
that was disgusting like imagine having
a chef that's [ __ ] privileged okay
yeah no i truly can't relate
i'm ready for chili season i think we're
about a week away we're in the 60s today
it's 63 degrees that's like cold i know
but look outside you're not going to eat
a chili with like looking out the way
actually you don't look well so i live
in a bunker with no windows so it's
actually chilly day every day because
the air conditioning is always on and i
never know what the weather is like last
night walked out into a
hurricane
and had no [ __ ] idea because i live
in a bunker and my search to see the
snow before christmas is bleak you guys
like i have a search in you know street
easy all these places
not even that specific criteria like i
want to leave a cast a wide net
there are days like most days there's
not even one update like not even one
new apartment that's really crazy yeah
so
it'll happen for you no if i like don't
no it's
sure whatever okay
well we actually will be discussing
christmas today in the fast five so we
can
start to think about how we can
cultivate this vibe for you yeah in the
worst case scenario which is that you're
still in your apartment it's looking
very likely wow shocking
okay i think without further ado we
should get into the past five stories
that you need to know before you take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
blenders fresh from san diego california
comes the only sunglasses brand that
we're ever gonna wear again we're
talking about blender's eyewear and
you're gonna be just as hooked when you
see how awesome
these shades are fabulous styles such a
variety great selection
their goal is to create adventurous
mid-priced eyewear options with the same
cool factor as other leading brands and
unlike expensive big brand shades that
you probably lost or smashed in the past
blenders are actually affordable so
you're not going to cry as much when the
inevitable happens because you ain't
lived until you've you know your
sunglasses have flown off while you're
running on blender's team in-house
designers are constantly coming out with
new styles from orange polarized
wraparounds tortoiseshell frames with
purple lenses to classic gold arms on
black lenses they also have prescription
glasses readers and blue lights as well
as a snow collection with goggles and
accessories i have their blue light
glasses which i constantly wear before
bed while watching downton abbey and
they're fabulous
live life in forward motion with
blenders and if you want to score 15 off
your blunders purchase visit
blenderseyewear.com and enter the promo
code toastvip that's blenderseyeware.com
code toast vip for 15 off blenders
rocked with pride worldwide thank you
claudia it's a pleasure i just want to
let everyone know today's stories
include a a lot of sad couple news a cm
scn we've had a lot of happy couple news
recently and so now of course what goes
up what the couple's giveth the couples
also take it the way yeah so the first
couple that broke up elon musk and
grimes have broken up after three years
together yeah everyone like get your
tissue box ready
elon musk and grimes have broken up
after three years together page six can
exclusively reveal the spacex founder
confirmed that he and the canadian
singer are semi-separated but remain on
good terms and continue to co-parent
their one-year-old son x-a-e-a-x-i-musk
he said he said musk said not a source
musk himself told page six oh we did he
responded to the email he responded to
the email he said we are semi-separated
but still love each other still see each
other frequently and are on great terms
it's mostly that my work at spacex and
tesla requires me to be primarily in
texas or traveling overseas and her work
is primarily in la she's staying with me
now and baby x is in the adjacent room
however it's worth noting that this uh
earlier this month they were at the met
gala together she walked the carpet
alone but he met her inside why didn't
he walk the carpet maybe i don't know
maybe he was feeling shy yeah
and then he had his after party at zero
bond i know that would really hurt for
you that that you weren't there yes i i
didn't know how to tell you the news
elon had a party at you know
the one night i don't go he threw like a
big met gala after party at zero bond i
was literally there last night and then
grimes was there and they were
photographed leaving together the next
day so it's like
there's definitely not bad blood here
like i do believe them when they say
scheduling conflict
yeah of course because like you know
being the richest man in the world like
meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcast podcasts
i'm shocked by this like really truly
shocked even though i don't even like
ship so hard like i don't really
understand grimes at all and i don't
know who the perfect woman for
elon musk is but
i've never felt particularly
moved by their story
so yeah i'm sad for them but i will move
on and this means we get to play like
who's elon dating next and that's such a
fun game i just feel like if he has the
time and space x to date then he's gonna
be with grimes like i think grimes is
his lady it reminds me of just bruno and
magnolia like they don't see each other
for a while because like their moms
can't meet up but when they're like he's
the only one for her i don't know i also
feel like and i don't know if this is
just like me not being a feminist but i
feel like
a person like elon musk like doesn't
have time this is gonna be terrible like
doesn't like have time for a partner
with a career if that makes sense like
someone who can travel overseas with him
and like be with the baby and like just
it's like honey and kim yeah exactly
yeah i think he's looking for more of
like a stay-at-home mom than a
touring
artist well i guess i guess if she could
go everywhere with him then they're
scheduling they could stay
yeah
i guess i don't know i think these two
like i think this is just like a
temporary ship is like at the port has
repairs but it's going back out to sea
that's my theory i don't like a you know
have a ticket on this ship like i really
don't care about this relationship i'm
in the first class cabin no i know you
are i just like really do not understand
the scripture of
no that's not the joke
whatever i just don't understand grime
so like i don't feel
vested in this okay that's fine i just i
ship elon being happy and worthy and in
love
and like family man
has five other kids no i know like you
wanna know something crazy he has five
other kids which we knew yeah and three
of them are triplets
what yeah yes okay like i think one of
the most under
discussed things is that like before
elon musk was famous he had like a wife
and like a very normal life
yeah he was just like a really rich guy
with like a pretty blonde wife who gave
him five kids yeah and he just like was
into his technology in spaceships and
like where is she
i'm sure she's happy and doing well
she's an author oh cute
so i don't relate to you
excuse me
i don't relate to you now do you know
that song no yes you do cause i'd never
treat me this shitty
you made me hate this city
and i don't talk [ __ ] about you on the
internet never told anyone anything bad
cause that shit's embarrassing
you okay so i'm seeing really eyelash
tomorrow is that billy eilish yes it's
so good i know the one line from like
real from tick tock yeah you are
literally the friend who watches
recycled tick tocks on rails but you
know what however you get your fix like
living life i didn't know that was
really it sounds like olivia
rodrigo that was not england
really like there were so many times
this morning where i could have stopped
you dead in your tracks called you out
you could have yeah and i don't but you
know what and that's the lesson here
you're better than me and that was a
mistake um yes it's bailey eilish and
like she's just been starting to like
sing that song out live because she's
playing in a festival last night it's
natural
and
it looks so lit and i'm gonna be there
tomorrow oh very cool i watched without
sound
you're going to be there tomorrow
because she's performing at global
citizens yes very cool i'm happy for you
me too like
i'm going to be like
like such a gen z or like
we'd
so good okay we need to move on to our
other bout of sad couple news jason
derulo has split from jennifer's four
months after welcoming a son this is
disgusting he decided to part ways he
announced it like super informally in a
tweet it was basically just like leave
us alone we want privacy he said jenna
and i have decided to part ways she's an
amazing mother but we feel being a part
of this time will allow us to be the
best versions of ourselves and the best
parents we could be please respect our
privacy at this time
i'm shook
do you feel like disrespecting their
privacy and like discussing what could
have happened
absolutely okay so
here's the thing like jason derulo is
like the biggest star on tick tock he
has 50 million followers
and he really like you know i i never
really knew about his personal life
until tick-tock and him and jenna are
like always making content she's like a
huge star on tick-tock too she's like
doing brand new meet through tic-tac
where she came up on tick-tock because
like she was his leading lady the latter
cool and i just feel like i know them
very well and then she got pregnant i'm
like this is so cute like a young family
getting started like on tick tock it's
beautiful and i'm tick tock family i'm
shook i'm not gonna lie like this is
crazy first of all they had maybe four
months ago so
what went wrong yeah and i'm just shook
by this yeah and i don't know i just
feel like jenna's not the problem you
think something nefarious happened here
no not cheating not cheating no that's
not what i'm thinking
i just feel like i don't know
i don't know i don't know what i feel
i'm just really concerned
interesting i don't think anything
nefarious do you
well yeah because well nefarious is you
know a wide-ranging term but it's such a
great term it's not just like scheduling
conflict because like you have a four
month old like you just work through
those things it's something that can't
be worked through and that makes me
think nefarious
i understand your logic and i quite
agree okay
so i was just really surprised by this
and like sad
yeah
and like justice for jenna i don't know
what happened but i just
just was forgetting that like she just
had a baby yeah
very very sad news i mean all these
ships going down
you hate to see it it's literally like
the titanic
truly are you ready for our next story
which is some exciting holiday news is
it the exciting holiday news that's
brought to you by noon by chance yes it
is what are the odds yes it is
all right you guys knew
everything of the sort
here's why
i mean everything in the store we try to
tell you all the time that we're gonna
we try to tell you all the time but like
sometimes words just can't do it justice
you know what i'm saying yeah no results
do it justice you don't need rules to
lose weight and just the knowledge and
wisdom to help you build smarter more
sustainable habits so noon's cognitive
behavioral approach helps you unlearn
bad habits and better understand your
relationship with food one size does not
fit all so choose your goals and new
will personalize a weight loss program
for you eighty percent of new users
finish the program and over sixty
percent have stuck with their goals for
at least a year with the noom taking
care of your health is empowering
instead of stressful there's no need to
fear ruining the whole program with one
day off because noon will help you get
back on track and all you need is 10
minutes there's all all they're asking
is 10 minutes from you to check in
there's no grueling or early mornings
huge chunks out of your day nume is a
fabulous program it's backed by science
it's nourishing instead of restrictive
and it offers a psychology based
approach
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com toast that's n o
o m dot com slash toast to sign up for
your trial noom.com toast what do you
have to lose thank you for that claudia
noom is really everything of the sword
if you're looking to meet some of your
health goals check it out okay our next
story is kelly clarkson's christmas
album when christmas comes around
tracklist has dropped the collabs are
insane the covers are sickening you guys
and this is what's going to get us
rolling into holiday season just really
quickly i was giggling
all day yesterday about i was like
telling everyone about this great joke
we made about like christmas being
canceled with the elf old tweets if you
didn't watch yesterday's episode it was
particularly hilarious yeah no it was
really funny the elf with old tweets
christmas all okay
tracklist is here here are the collabs
that she has going on for this album
first a song with chris stapleton called
glow it's gonna be gorgeous it's gonna
be insane chris stapleton is just out
here like making dreams come true you
know he's on the red album with taylor
swift collab kelly clarkson collab just
fabulous fabulous stuff also she's
clapping with ari which just goes to
show what we're saying earlier this week
about the voice judge camaraderie is
everything of the sort no this is
synergy like i can get behind yeah
they're singing santa can't you hear me
which
i
it's not after our discussion yesterday
i thought it was ari's original song
yeah but no it's just a real song that's
out there i'm just gonna i don't know
all these christmas songs santa can't
you hear me like every time i say wait
santa can you hear me can't
okay cause santa can you hear me as a
song by britney spears
yeah
maybe it's an original yeah maybe it's
like the pov other perspective from the
britney spears song
yeah then we have a collab with brett
eldredge under the mistletoe which is a
kelly original and it's [ __ ]
fantastic
oh no under mistletoe i'm sorry justin
bieber saying that too so um not a kelly
original what's this one you're here
now i went away
alone on christmas day
which one's that
it's so good i have to pull up wrapped
in red give me a second wrapped in by
the way
i'm gonna say one negative thing about
this about wrapped in red no
just comparing to wrapped in red
the imagery the marketing like the
assets being used the photo shoot not my
favorite i don't think it's holiday
enough i like really cheesy ass like big
red bows she's wearing like a purple
dress she looks gorgeous but i'm just
not into the styling it's a little you
know like
non-denominational holiday when i'm very
much looking for christmas okay
interesting i believe it's underneath
the tree was the song that we were just
singing
and
okay i yeah it's hard to top wrapped in
red and so obviously she just wrapped
herself in purple instead right um
but i
i give myself over to kelly clarkson i
love that her and ari are doing a collab
like that makes me so happy like talk
about two queens who are definitely just
like nice you know yeah and talented
like the pipes on the songs okay also
some of the exciting news is are the
songs that she's singing a lot of
originals a lot of like covers of kelly
songs and a lot of covers of iconic
christmas songs such as
all i want for christmas is you oh my
god yes like i had never even thought of
it but like has kelly ever even sang
that song i've gotta go on a deep dive a
rabbit hole like seeing if there's a
cover of it somewhere because that's
gonna be gorgeous yeah
it's all it's all stunning the album
comes out october 15th i know we talked
about it yesterday but like i feel like
once that album comes out and it's a
little earlier than i usually start
celebrating i start celebrating chilly
season yet i start celebrating on
november 1st usually like after
halloween we do our halloween episode
and then i can throw myself into the
holidays but i think october 15th is the
start date this year wow because kelly
because of kelly that's what she said
what she said she said what she said and
she did not stutter no
she did not um can kelly do the whistle
tone like that ahri and
mariah carey could do like that i can do
it i don't know if she can do what they
can do but she has her own
you know i was just we i think we all
yeah i was just wondering like if she
does that yeah i don't think so because
as far as i know the only people who can
do it are ari
yeah she's in a different um like
structural range yeah so it's just
different
for sure not better or worse just
different
are you ready for our next story
super mario brothers the animated movie
has a star-studded cast i did see this
and i thought some of the casting was
really good
yeah
chris pratt is playing mario super mario
anya taylor joy is in it she's playing
princess peach then we also have jack
black charlie who's jack black gonna be
um
hold on
i like the thing that i saw earlier had
it all like easy too
yeah but this article is having it's
giving me a harder time hold on i'll
just google it i think jack maybe he's
bowser that's pretty
that's pretty on point
okay it doesn't say one
um
jack black is bowser very good thank you
charlie day is luigi keegan michael key
toad
seth rogan donkey kong
fred armisen
not on my current list so obviously not
relevant enough and then i guess these
are subsequent characters kevin michael
richardson sebastian maniscalco and
charles
happy first sebastian menescalco like
yeah no he's got a good voice yeah and
he's literally like the hardest working
man in comedy
yeah so this is really exciting i mean i
think this is gonna be a really good
movie just based on the fact that like
what's the movie like it's a video game
no but so they're gonna there's gonna be
a plot like something's going on wario
is you know wario trying to do stuff
trying to start stuff always right i
think they'll they'll make they'll write
a nice plot so
excuse me
mario is like an american voice right
but luigi is luigi no
i don't know if mario is american
yeah he's like
oh you know
yeah
like but luigi is like
he's italian yeah but i thought mario's
italian too
we'll find out soon i would love to hear
like a prequel how they were raised you
know maybe that's what this is what made
them them what made them super exactly
what made them brothers and what made
mario the main character and not luigi
main character energy does that
cause problems between the brothers i
think luigi like he just
is happy to be there it's happy to be
there he obviously believes in mario's
vision and just wants to support i think
the whole crew really believes in
mario's vision i think we all believe in
mario
we all believe in mario are you ready
for our fifth and final story little
fashion news
i'm sorry what was that
we have actually some background music
today yes we hired a band we had a band
they're called the jackhammers
it's the triangles and the jackhammers
performing the final story
[Music]
don't forget about princess peach and
bowser
don't forget about princess peach and
bowser no i ship them hardcore either
bastard's like the villain right like
we're trying to beat bowser at the end i
don't know there is a lot of infighting
amongst because also like if we're
playing and i'm peach and mario we're
against each other right but at the end
of the day we're all brothers but we're
also always rescuing peach like she's
always getting her
dumb self into trouble i don't know it's
just because they're dressed too big she
can't she doesn't run as fast she
doesn't have the mobility and the
agility of the other characters 100 you
know so she needs a modernization i'm
sure ang and tyler taylor joy will be
like i think peach deserves a backstory
usher peach into the modern era she'll
be like she's an inventor literally like
how i know exactly what you're thinking
like emma watson yeah beauty and the
beast and what did we watch recently
cinderella
i keep seeing clips of cinderella i've
perm i've set up shop on cinderella's
slander side of tick tock and it's so
fabulous
um i saw like clips of them like singing
regular songs
in like the village
but you sent me some of the clips out of
context that like yes out of context
they look really silly but in the moment
watching him that didn't stand out to me
as one of the bad moments well you're
alone in that
i guess okay our last story little do
you think there's anyone on the planet
whose favorite movie is cinderella yes
a hundred percent the kiln look at bayo
version yes okay like there are camilla
cabello stands they probably also love
the story of cinderella and to them this
was a dream come true like the heavens
smile down on them and they can't
believe they're locked like for me
that's how i feel about greatest showman
like that this year that's actually like
factually based a great movie like
you know i'm sure you could find critics
and they would say do you think there's
anyone who it's their favorite movie
and here i am no
no here i am this is me
this is real
wrong this is me
still a very good this is me yeah but
just like the wrong one for the occasion
um okay so the fifth and final story is
brought to you by liquid death you guys
the most interesting water bottle brand
well not bottle actually that's
their that's why it's so interesting
that's right so interesting aluminum
cans super pregnant you're drinking
liquid death it's just water someone's
gonna think you're drinking a beer
they're gonna knock the beer out of your
hand and you're gonna say sir
this is liquid death water
that's what you're gonna say
it's why it's called liquid death
because it will brutally murder your
thirst and their infinitely recyclable
tall boy cans are helping bring death to
plastic bottles they also donate 10 of
the profits from every can sold to help
kill plastic pollution
so
it's twofold one it's just like a
hilarious bit like you drinking a beer
but it's actually water and then also
there's a really nice meeting behind it
it's good for the environment we're
trying to get rid of plastic and
aluminum cans are recyclable which is
fabulous so if you want to get free
shipping on all their water and you can
get merch liquid death dot com slash
toast again that's liquid death dot com
toast or they also sell liquid death at
whole foods in 7-eleven so you should
check it out
thank you for that claudia get on your
zoom class with your professor
start drinking it
that's funny yeah
our fifth and final story little fashion
news savage x fenty show volume three
kicked off in los angeles and is going
to premiere on amazon prime video today
so you can see all the fashions of the
fashion show tons of celebs star-studded
walking in the show showing off the
threads there were performances normani
performed
and notably missing was one former
savage fenty
ambassador erica jane
did she walk in the show i don't know
but she's just been like a huge part of
their brand and i think that maybe she's
like if things had gone differently like
this was the year she would have been in
the show because like she started a
really long partnership with them wow
that's a really really good point yeah
so the show comes out today really
exciting a lot of models sydney
crawford's walking emily ratakowski
and then there's so many slums in
attendance rihanna should have had linda
evangelista yeah but like this was
filmed before like before we knew yeah
but this has really become like
victoria's secret fashion show you know
no it's crazy how like so much has
changed oh and everyone was freaking out
because adriana lima's in it which is
like such a big deal that is because
adriana lima is like the victoria's
secret angel and now she's working for
the competition my my how the tables
have turned literally but like that's
like when you watch savage fenty show
you like understand why victoria like
fell so hard so fast like it's the most
inclusive people of all different sizes
shapes colors and it's just like
victoria seeker could never compete like
ever yeah and i love that like this is
the standard now yeah but it really is
like the same idea and the performances
and everything i never really realized
have we spoken about the lingerie of
savage ex-fenty because like it's fire
no we haven't spoken about the designs
themselves i don't really wear lingerie
i don't wear laundry either but i see a
lot of the savage fenty stuff on my
instagram because like i follow girls
who are brand ambassadors i guess um and
it's the cutest things such cute things
such cute things yeah
you should get some i know like
i should
just thinking about just ruminating okay
cool well i don't have too much tv to
share but i do need to talk about nine
perfect strangers i need to i need to
get it off my chest because
everything about the show should have
been amazing like first of all the anne
moriarty book like turned into a tv show
wonderful wellness retreat sign me up
again nicole kidman nicole the cat every
single cast member is perfectly cast
well
we'll get to that and it's like such a
great premise for a show like nine
strangers on a spooky retreat what could
go wrong everything
so i started it when it first came out
and i was trying to follow along and
like i wasn't loving it but i was just
like pushing myself because i'm like
this is the show that's out there right
now and this is what we're gonna be
watching right after like four episodes
i was like i can't do this to myself
anymore like tv should not make me
cringe and make my skin crawl like i'm
not watching but then the other day i
was talking to dana and she was like i'm
obsessed with nine perfect strangers we
just watched a second to last episode
it's amazing it's finally getting really
good i love when people say that like
the second to last episode it's finally
getting good so like it's not good no
but like ever maybe everything like
starts they lay all this groundwork for
like six episodes and now the payoff
comes which for sure i'm just saying
fundamentally it's based on a book like
i can understand that and i can i can i
can get with it no because fundamentally
if a show is not good till the second to
last episode that means that nine out of
ten of the or eight out of ten of the
episodes are not good that makes it a
bad show just by logic no i don't make
the rules it doesn't necessarily have to
be a bad show but if it's like you're
not understanding but by the time you
understand it well it will it's just
it's like reading a book literally
for so long you're like waiting and then
it's like is the payoff going to be is
the solution to what we
the problems we've been reading gonna
like blow your mind okay so whatever she
was like it's amazing you should watch i
was like you know what and she's not
even like a huge pop culture person i'm
like if she loved the show so much like
i'm gonna watch it so i started again
last night and
it's atrocious
it's atrocious it i couldn't believe it
was worse than the beginning that i told
you i still didn't get to the
penultimate episode that she was talking
about because like my skin was crawling
and i'm just like tv's supposed to be
entertaining enjoy it and i am
so cringe and i have to be honest like
it's nicole kidman oh it's masha wow
that's a hot [ __ ]
it's the accent like it's awful if i
could skip through her scenes maybe i
could enjoy the show because you know
melissa mccarthy's doing her thing being
sort of funny um and with um bobby kind
of ballet they're like
got a little something brewing
um and some of the other cast stories
some are
interesting uh something's gonna happen
with luke evans so i'm curious about
that
but i can't fast forward through the
mash's stuff because that's all the
spooky mystery parts so i was like
i'm calling
it a day with this awful awful show i'm
so glad to hear that because i started
it and i thought it was atrocious and
people said i didn't give enough of my
energy but i do feel like i did and when
i posted that she just nicole came and
deserves a razzy for this
i got so much support oh okay so many
people like people who i'm like friends
with in real life like being like thank
you it's awful and then also of course
you know like toasters being like yes
and
razzie sees it right and that just like
the show is bad the book is bad and
i'm just really shocked that this is
where i've landed i purposely did not
read the book so that i could enjoy the
show because you can't do both ever
because you're going to be like it's not
as good as the book
and
this is what i get this is the things i
get that acts and i'm sorry like
everything about masha and just like her
like touching
and like her talking and her whispering
no
no the thing is is like when you're
nicole kidman and you have such a unique
niche you know rich older woman you
really shouldn't stray too far away from
that and i'm afraid going to like a
russian spiritual healer is not going it
doesn't fit under the category of things
nicole goodman is good at
she plays the same character in every
single show and i gave her so long in
the show before i was like no it's you
in the beginning like if someone told me
in the beginning like her accent is so
bad i try not to like get bogged down by
stuff like that because i'm not an actor
i don't do accents so who am i to be
like this is a bad accent you know i
know a real russian accent but just like
the whispering oh
like since this chilled on my spine i'm
so sorry it was just
no
no and today i was on spotify on my
release radar and i saw that keith urban
released a song for nine perfect
strangers called crimson blue and i was
like everything about this has all the
makings of something that i would
literally love and adore
and i can't well and i can't see them
working together i'm not going to lie
like the best couple in hollywood and i
just want to say i'm saying it now and
i'm i actually really mean this
if i ever
sit down at the show and we're
discussing a story
we're nicole kidman and keith urban are
not together anymore
it will be the last show we ever do okay
that's the only thing that can break up
this show okay
it's a good thing we don't have to worry
i don't know
after what i just
what i saw right you know what it
actually made me miss outlander so i put
it back on wow i put it back on i was
like at least my you know i
my skin was crawling less with outlander
yeah but now of course like jamie's back
with in captivity with the red codes
i don't think i'm turning it back on and
it sees it's episode 14 i'm about to
watch and episode 17. 16.
there's only 16 episodes in the first
season
and it's obviously something that
happens while he's in
captured
well he's captured i don't know so i
don't know any context like of who's who
so this might be where
but you know what jane eyre has been
wonderful a delight i've been reading it
before bed just to get me you know to
help me fall asleep and get you nice and
bored no exactly and it's really i mean
i'm nowhere i'm like 10 in but it's been
delightful so that's something that's
good fabulous but it's really been a
wash of a content week for me honestly
um well i can't really no i know
just living in downton
and i'll probably finish it this weekend
which is so sad
but i'm gonna take it slow no it's good
you need to finish it so we can actually
talk about it i know um okay you guys
that's our show
i really don't have the energy to do our
wrap-up like do you want to do it today
sure i mean you don't like how i do it
because i don't do it the same way as
you i won't complain i put my own like
space yeah no be yourself thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
of the millennium morning show where we
deliver the past five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
around 10 30 a.m
um if you're watching the show that
means that you probably liked it if you
watched for this long or you like to
engage in you know
torturing yourself just like just like
me watching nine perfect strangers and
you just want to turn into a stand-up
set and you just want to watch stuff
that makes your skin crawl but if you're
not that person and you're watching
because you enjoyed the show please you
know leave a thumbs up on this video if
you're listening as a podcast a
five-star review in the podcast store
let us know how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
and we shall see you tomorrow you can
always follow us and keep up on
instagram at the morning toast my
personal instagram is at jackie ashrae
and i do believe the content is premium
that is what people say is yes
yeah and then we also have girls no job
club was no job pups with no job
there's a lot there's a lot out there
for you so we will see you on monday if
you've made it this far into the episode
you are now part of the society season
two
and in commemoration of season two of
this society please leave an emoji of
a dog because we honor bruno today even
though we've done that one before but
yes in honor of brewer please leave the
first puppy emoji that looks like brew
and have an amazing weekend everyone we
will see you on monday love you goodbye